foreign
so imagine this all right okay let's say
we all
run a daycare center okay in a place
called Clarkson sucks watch out for this
guy's closed all right stores closed we
come back one day
suddenly they're stolen diapers
they're stolen baby formula why would
you steal it and there's a note left
behind right
uh including a hundred and twenty
dollars and on this handwritten note
uh they're asking if the our daycare has
adult sized diapers and if we would
quote play along oh let's have some sexy
time [__] freak
all right you mean is that so common
some sexy time [__] you know those dudes
that like to act like babies oh oh oh he
wants to come in as a baby I think he's
watching porn since he's five oh Malone
we come back a day or two later but
remember that note's got 120 bucks next
to it yeah but he's only stolen a couple
diapers and a little bit of formula
right wait so he broke in broke in took
some diapers some baby formula left a
note says play along left 120 bucks kind
of consider it come back a couple days
later same thing now there's 200 there a
little bit more diapers a little bit
more baby okay now we're talking now I
could get maybe a place to survive soon
with the 120 but I'm calling the [__]
cops man there's 200 a little bit you
got to do a sting operation
hey but it's a service right he's like
can you take can you babysit
here's 200 bucks next time you said me
next time it comes in though no includes
sizes for pants shoes bras and dresses
and uh the no Inc indicates that this
person would like to play as a baby girl
and wants to be called Baby Danielle oh
no girl I always thought this was common
with like dudes I think it is a dude
it isn't very nice of you oh [__] a
little girl oh [__]
I think I'm stupid
just like duh she's like yeah that's why
I'm married dude that wants to be a
little toddler girl his name is Daniel
stealer or stealer and he's 65 years old
oh that wants to be Benjamin Button and
then he wants to be benjalina button
dude
I'm always impressed when people with
that bizarre of a mental defect reach
that age is that high or do you think
they develop it later they must have
closeted it for quite a while you think
they always wanted to be a baby and
they're like [__] it I'm about to die
I'm just gonna be a baby I think they
really shut that stuff out yeah it's I
mean and everybody now he's on social
security so he's got a little bit of
money yeah so you do some [__] and he's
a little almost there like adult diapers
nursing home like yeah but somebody's
got to take care of him in a daycare
center call him baby Danielle he wants
to go wow
how common is this do you guys think it
is though right one in three I bet one
in three two of us a lot of freaks in
here all right who's gonna do it not
everybody do you think that who wants to
be a baby do you think that makes them
horny no I'm not that kind of horny sure
Joe I'm not that kind of horny I bet it
all no oh
[Laughter]
and I win oh when you when you have a
kink like let's say like you like feed
or something does that mean you look at
feet and you get a big fat boner yeah
sometimes sometimes you're definitely
sexually aroused by it instantly come
and sometimes it just compels you to
like the thirst for it in certain ways
like you need to go affixiate that that
Thirst by seeing and touching it being
around or some [__] like that
laughs
that's better that's better
hey you know I'm the guy in the military
that empathizes off
instead of emotional things to make them
feel better yeah Joplin likes feet
the chaplain's kinky bro yeah because I
always thought like when you get dressed
up because I like to be I try to like
understand people I'm like if you get
dressed up in a diaper and you're saying
Google gaga like are you saying Google
gag out the fat ass boner or is it like
you do the whole role play thing and
then later on you get horny maybe
because you know those videos where like
guys like to get their junk stepped on
or suck oh you don't have boners oh yeah
yeah but they love it but the guy what
about the karate guys
karate guys yeah we're getting there
punching themselves in the [__] or
having like their buddy kick him in the
car first of all it's Kung Fu I don't
know they're getting big fat boners from
it they're not turned on you think that
there's an element of that mentally and
uh in addiction-wise that's not sexual
though probably maybe oh my God like
what like what is it not sex related
it's not sex related like like it's
filling a void of some some other reason
it's not sexual even though it's
addictive oh like like a OCD tendency
right no some people do like oh [__] I
gotta turn darn on by four times like
you got a complex it feels so good oh my
God like that right or I think for them
it's turning the doorknob four times not
because it's like it feels good it's
like a sigh of relief as far as like
okay I did that now I can move on so I
think it's a Japanese guy that wanted to
be a dog
that seems less sexual but it maybe
that's just like a purely mental yeah
it's all sexual dude maybe they're all
just trying to charge up the spank bags
that's just Japanese that's true
that's a good explanation because
there's like a whole 20 Squad of
Japanese that all want to be cholos and
[__] but they're not like a cholo orgy
you think that's sexual they're just no
no but they're that's just like Japanese
will go in like when they do stuff they
find the culture a hobby or something
and then they bam he loves doc so much
that he has to be one what happened to
just like people want to [__] firemen
and policemen normal [__] or the cops
and robbers wanted enough bullies to
keep that going I want to [__] the
teacher yeah that's how I know I'm
normal because pornos I like the real
estate agents real estate ladies is one
of the best things you've ever said by
the way because you put me on some good
because I forgot about how hot chicks
are in Panthers but I never see [__]
in pantsuits almost ever because
shoulder pads Nikki used to wear them
like auditioning because sometimes you'd
play a role it's like that so I remember
now I'm like oh I hearken back to the
days where she'd walk out of the house
in a pantsuit and I'm like that was hot
as [__] damn you said Harkin you think
yeah it's hotter than chicks are in like
a business suit it is kind of you think
this is role-playing like that but it's
different like it's like how like oh
yeah she's wearing hot clothes and then
that's like us being mild and these guys
are hardcore so they're like yeah man
they're [__] an elephant
and then they're horny wait wait that
jumps really fast or like like an animal
like a dog or like or like a baby maybe
it's like level one it's like you're
attracted to a girl in like you know
Panthers because like she's kind of a
boss it's like Halloween costumes you're
a boss and then but you want to be like
in bondage because you want to feel like
you know you're submissive level three
you're like I just want to be a full-on
baby yeah you know what I'm saying but
see that's still that's still simulating
it to a degree like having sex with an
elephant is very different than hey
dress up like an elephant
I don't think it is
or like maybe like he's like oh I want
to be a school girl but then like he got
younger and he's a baby now you know
this like oh that's it's weird he keeps
going back in time oh anime I made a
poopy I don't get what sexual hold on
yeah and I do think we should just
arrest these people I think it's just
for the desire to pick them up even if
they're paying you pretty good yeah just
pick them up yeah because you don't know
keep an eye on this yes yeah you don't
think we have rights too
I I usually believe that but not out of
daycare bro where there's other children
and [__] that's the weirdest that's
[__] weird that's the weirdest part
if you got a guy that's like cover me in
[__] exactly you're like okay I get
that okay
the Hershey's factory like that you're
like you're gonna contaminate the
chocolate get out of here yeah dude but
and the other guy that's like like the
whip means oh yeah I like that like I
kind of get that too a little bit but
then the goo goo gaga uh I [__] myself
wiped me up and Daddy I mean
like why isn't it good enough [__]
that's crazy honestly just firing squad
and then you're 65. you know what I mean
like imagine you're 65 and you're making
a I I mean what if you're like I want
Mommy milk mommy milk
[Laughter]
[Music]
what about them furries though they do
that they just wear their outfits that
seems so much milder compared to this
yeah I think so too plus it seems like
that's also like a society dude I think
a furry right sense of belonging but
it's not sex furry goes like this to
this the furry goes
yeah
because they're not breaking into animal
shelters to like be weird worries or
judging this [__] yeah they're just
their tail on the string is going like
back and forth furries are like these
guys are giving us a bad name you know
okay this is the reason why I think this
is weird is like it's like going to
Massage Envy and asking them to jack you
off that's not their job
is it yeah like going to a kindergarten
and asking them to teach you like a
child that's weird whose job is it red
dragon massage yeah red dragon massage
parlor in Chinatown Emerald Lotus
reflexology foot spa that's what it's
called that's what's up so who goes
to the side hey can I get the extra
extra
oh you know what's weird have you ever
have you guys heard of soothe
oh the app the app we hired someone and
had to go did they jack you off no um
yeah tell us the truth so it's like no
he [__] me so Jill's one of those
people that like um never like she never
really takes care of herself like she
always puts other people first so she'll
like literally be like oh like that
right I'm gonna go get a goddamn massage
I'm good and she's like that for like I
don't know like three months I'm like
[__] and I was like I bet I could
[__] find a massage so I downloaded
sooth and I hired some and then you
could pick like people step on you guy
girl Sports whatever and then I was like
well I was like just trying to figure
out yeah I picked one that was more like
stress relieving and then uh he came in
and then I was like watching TV and and
he was working on her and then Jill was
saying that like this guy had like this
weird
hard dick Vibe like it was like it was
supposed to be the stress relieving so
it should feel like Massage Envy where
it's like you know like it feels like
more therapeutic but then it was more of
like she go they would be like this and
then like
oh he's pouring this boner on her back
yeah I feel that she's like I don't want
to do it ever again is it like that
Instagram massage Guy where he's got
that girl and he looks like he's just
[__] doggy styling her oh he's like
dry humping her I love that guy the
cracker the guy who does the crack yeah
yeah but for some reason she's gotta be
in like a thong bikini too there's
candles everywhere and they're just
greased the [__] up I don't know what
the [__] that was man that's a good
career that's watching TV that guy's
[__] massaging March watching TV he
goes and you enjoying that sports
massage
no Bart's over here he's like oh no
so I didn't pay rent
like this I could tell that all your
stress is right come on dude
the heck
[Music]